good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
and happy friday
friday you gotta get down on friday
we have absolutely no choice but to
acknowledge the space that we are
currently in because one
it is friday there is so much hope on
the horizon for us do not forget to
acknowledge the space that you're in
two it is the third anniversary happy
birthday to
the morning toast three years ago on
this day with the tenacious spirit and
bad lighting we walked into our studio
wearing cool lots
and uh leggings probably if i could
remember correctly
and we started we went where no other
podcaster dared to go
long island city we started our journey
three years ago today wow
what a big day that was for us and here
we are three years later
i would say that we have grown up
we have grown up and we have grown up
beautiful thank you absolutely i think
that will be the title
growing up and glowing up we absolutely
love to see it to everyone who's been
here since the beginning we love you to
those we lost along the way we don't
miss you
and to those who are new here welcome to
another three years
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome to
the morning toast
today's a great day you know what's a
great day for it's a great day to tell
someone you love
about the morning toast and be like you
know what it's a new year for the toast
it's time to get in
on the third floor sorry you missed the
bottom three
and you're gonna have to take the stairs
you're gonna have to take the stairs to
the third floor
still beautiful doable join us on this
journey
please and while you're joining us on
this journey
as always do not forget to acknowledge
the space that you're in so and and
today you will find
that if you acknowledge the space that
you're in it's an amazing space first of
all
it's friday oh my god we worked so hard
for this year always a beautiful view
from a friday we made it thank you
rebecca black for
just existing it's also fearless
taylor's version friday right so i don't
know if you guys can see i'm wearing my
taylor um
era's merch but this one only has
folklore she keeps releasing it with
every album homegirl doesn't have
[ __ ] releasing i don't know
how many sweatshirts can i get snitch is
really conflicted about if she should
keep up with every era sweatshirt i
don't want to go for
because like they make you guys so happy
i know but you know what i am going to
get a new one because
i was like so late to the website that i
only got gray and i'm not like crazy
about the gray like the white better
so the next one i will get well it works
for today because i'm wearing um
some toast merch to celebrate the one
year anniversary oh wait i'm sorry three
year anniversary i always show you dress
up for our anniversary i need to look at
my time hop and see things that i've
worn in the past but this is the first
time our anniversary falls on a friday
so like i'm not wearing a dress
this is what happens when casual friday
meets toast diversary yeah
but my i could have worn a skirt and i'm
i think i'm going to hit skirt season
soon my legs just like aren't ready they
need like a tan a tan locks
and everything but i think next week you
will be seeing my legs wow really
something i can promise you guys like
chubby girls will understand like the
anxiety of like leg season being upon us
like i
cannot bear the thought it's
it's a scary thought which is why we
have to prepare i can't i can't
but you know what like adding skirts to
the repertoire like i've really run out
of things to wear and so
i'm looking forward to the skirts again
i'm happy for you
i love a script screw
um so we have a great show obviously
we're going to dive into the fearless of
it all it is a story
um but i just want to share like kind of
an experience that happened to me
yesterday
okay open up it's a safe space um
and i feel like it's kind of like
offends some people but i went to costco
okay which i don't really go to because
first of all i live in an apartment
costco is for people with ranches like
just
people with storage with barns like
places
pantries places to put the biggest pack
of crystal light you've ever seen in
your life like so unnecessary
and we went there's one in the city but
the one in the city is like not that
great
parking is bad and they don't sell
liquor so what's the point
so me and ben drove to new jersey
because we just we wanted liquor but
then we're like all right i guess we
could like get some stuff from costco
and i think i've only been to a costco
one other time in my life but
i wasn't like upset about the prospect
of going because my book is sold at
costco so i'm like great i could see it
on the
the book shelf you know get there my
book isn't even there you know but all
out
but all the people like say it was sold
out but all the people i see myself on
shelves with like the obamas like they
were there like of course they are but
like i wasn't
just say it was sold out yeah it was 100
sold out um
and i just like had a terrible time
now i know people live for ikea nothing
about this is surprising
costco gives me ikea vibes for sure
unnecessary
so big and just like overwhelming like i
went in there like ready to get like
major like snacks like everything
everything
literally i walked out like i i got
toilet paper and towels like i just
it was so overwhelming i couldn't fathom
like the size of it all the size of the
store the size of the products like
and all the products are like huge and
they're like up on shelves and like i
don't know how you get it like
it was so overwhelming and it's a store
that you literally need to spend the day
at and then spend the day like
organizing your house i don't have space
for that much toilet paper or that much
crystal light or that many rice crispy
treats like
it was so much and i just wanted to say
like i don't like costco
okay i mean you're entitled to your
opinion i think i've only ever been to
costco once
a lot of the reason people like costco
is because of the samples did you
but maybe they put them away because of
cove so then really what's the point
and like it does make sense like if you
have the space like why go grocery
shopping every week when you can
literally go once a year like these
packs of diet cokes like i wanted to
bite so bad
where the hell do you put that yeah i
literally live in an apartment with two
closets it's like how
so i get the idea and like i guess
that's why i was so busy because in new
jersey you live in a house like you have
space for that but
the one in the city like literally makes
no sense costco is the antithesis of
manhattan living
it was just like very overwhelming and i
just like i vlogged it on tick tock and
like
by the second i got to costco the vlog
was over because i was so overwhelmed
like i couldn't even be in the store let
alone vlog the experience
yeah so i didn't even post a tech talk
which i might later
it doesn't sound like no it was just
like so
taxing emotionally and still recovering
added to your list of unpopular opinions
that goes to show that you are not like
other girls
no no other girls love costco love
costco other girls
are nothing like me and i am nothing
like other girls and that's just the
moral of
this show i think just showing everyone
how you are not like other girls
no no i'm you're so different yeah
no and like honestly like i really like
prefer to hang out more like with guys
like
i'm just not really like a girls girl
and like i honestly just i love drinking
beer
i just feel like no one understands you
no no and i'm so
different and misunderstood yeah
it's really it's exhausting being me
they should write a movie about you
yeah the different girl
that's right that's you um okay we have
an amazing show for you guys keeping up
with the kardashians was on last night
the addison
ray of it you guys worst episode ever i
can't believe it was an episode that i
couldn't have been more excited for
it turned into my eyes glazed in the
back of my head i was
shocked and no offense i blame mj and
her birthday i'm not trying to
the end was sweet but like the the
subplot where shall we have
nj's birthday like you guys have a
million [ __ ] houses no i know i
figure it out i'm like stop trying to be
like the rest of us like looking for a
venue for your grandmother's birthday
party like we have those problems well i
don't have a grandma but if i did that
would be my problem you don't know
totally i blame like that storyline and
also like the bunker or kimmy schmidt
are you kidding the bunker
like are you kidding kim you're so busy
you're gonna spend five hours sweating
in a bunker
the bunker so i like they found a way to
absolutely ruin this episode and we'll
dive into it that's on that i
i was shocked because like that i
thought addison could carry the whole
right the whole hour um do you have the
real houses of dallas as a story
no i don't but i have a real housewives
story like a bravo story so
let me just say now that i brought it up
oh okay i filmed the dallas reunion
yesterday yes
everyone was like oh my god the tea is
so hot you know what the tea is
something crazy is going down yeah
carrie brittingham landed here tested
positive for coven
and traveled with brandy redmond so they
both had to
film virtually from their hotel rooms
which just sucks
sucks so hard not that crazy like not i
wouldn't call that everyone was making
it like so dramatic like there was this
big bombshell going to come out of the
room yeah like people were going to be
fired on live like on the spot live so
no nothing of the storm nothing of the
sort but
i do think without further ado to do to
do
where are you yeah it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
yeah
you in the back seat of the taxi before
you just stop
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode of the morning toast
is brought to you by manscaped the best
in below the waist grooming and hygiene
manscape obsesses over developing the
best technology to provide you with the
best tools for your grooming experience
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools for you or your man's family
jewels
and today they're offering our listeners
20 off plus free shipping
with the code toast at manscaped.com
manscape treated us with a bunch of
tools and formulations from their
perfect package 3.0 kit
the perfect cap package comes with the
perfect hair trimmer ever called the
lawnmower 3.0
the hilarious name by the way for like
an electric razor for your balls
their third generation trimmer features
a cutting-edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to the
thanks to their advanced skin safe
technology
you can feel confident shaving with
manscaped skin safe technology
the trimmer comes with an led light for
a more precise shave and it is
waterproof
to make your shower shave clean and easy
their brand new perfect package 3.0
comes with everything you need to keep
trimmed cut free and smelling
nice they also include the crop
preserver and crop reviver
which are products that can help prevent
sweat smell and stickiness
and all their products smell great
perfect for the man in your life
they use the best ingredients so you
have the best experience all their
formulations are
vegan cruelty free die free sulfate free
and
paraben free so you know that your man's
manhood is in good hands
they also throw in two free gifts for
their perfect package a pair of high
performance manscaped boxer briefs that
keep you fresh
all day and a travel shed bag to store
all your grooming goodies
by the way ben uses um all the manscaped
products it's his favorite razor
and the travel bag like every time we
travel i have like a million pouches
so when i pack ben's like grooming
essentials like i put it in like a
bright pink
leather casey like boys don't have
pouches you know yeah but manscape for
free they'll give you this like manly
leather and black one it's like really
cool
um so that's worth purchasing alone it
is a perfect tool for the man in your
life he will thank you and it's a great
gift
so again if you want to get 20 off and
free shipping use the code toast at
manscape.com
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code toast at manscape.com
thank you manscaped for making grooming
easy
love it okay let's dive right in we've
got much to discuss of first sign on and
escape your
man sign on escape your man for sure it
took me like a second to think of it
i'm glad you did the first story is the
big news of the day prince philip has
died
the love of queen elizabeth's life was
99.
the love of her life he's the love of
her life did you watch a crown
yeah and they had their trials and
tribulations but they were married 73
years yeah and he was a good
married 73 years because they had no
choice okay i don't want to get into
this i don't want to just create his
name i was just saying like
she loves him is that really the vibe
that you got
100 even though like he was like being
weird at first like
she put up with it because she loves him
she chose him she could have married
anyone in the whole [ __ ] world she
couldn't yeah
no for sure she chose him okay
who do you think she loves i mean she
did like that horoscope the horse guy
first of all
yeah and second of all no i'm not saying
that she doesn't love him i don't know
if it was like the
love of her life they were married for
72 years because they had to be
like well i mean everyone else found
loopholes for themselves
you know yeah but look at henry viii but
no one else okay
i guess fine you know it was the love of
her life sure
she made her choice yes and they made it
work she's just like too good of a queen
to like even think about getting a
divorce
well that's also because she had a
boyfriend now who knows where's the
horseman where's horsey
what was his name like chadwick like
patchy something like that yeah yeah
yeah
you guys will let us know yeah but
buckingham palace released a statement
it is with deep sorrow that her majesty
the queen announces the death of her
beloved husband his royal highness the
prince philip
duke of edinburgh his royal highness
passed away peacefully this morning
at windsor castle further announcements
will be made in due course the royal
family joined with people around the
world
in mourning his loss are you okay yeah
are you just so upset you said edinburgh
it's edinburgh
do you think that like is that
surprising to you what
did i say wrong
okay we're both saying wrong edinburgh
um first of all
condolences to the royal family it's
terrible loss a great leader
but you know to live to 99 as we say
judaism
is such a blessing yeah such a simple
and should be celebrated
it is a dream because in judaism we
always say like odd 120 like may you
live till 120.
but like 99 is pretty [ __ ] close and
you say until 120 like because that's
never gonna [ __ ] happen
right so it's a a miracle to live this
long
he will be dearly missed as a husband
grandfather father great grandfather
great great great grandfather great two
just great just great just great just
great um and it is a loss
but honestly i'm i'm looking at a single
queen elizabeth so
i want all the businessmen beau in all
the land to start lining up at
buckingham palace
we're going speed dating get in the car
we write it down wow i mean
queen elizabeth is going into a period
of mourning i literally didn't even
think of that yet like that's
sure we can entertain that i'm just like
really sad for the family he's like an
integral part yes
of an integral member an integral member
who wrote this article up people i mean
everyone
no it's kind of [ __ ] up that like the
media would kind of spoil the next
season
no but this this wouldn't be the next
season kidding this is like in many i
don't know if we'll ever get this no we
never will
um it's really sad i think it is sad
like it's
to lose a beloved member of your family
you know and such a world leader
world leader for sure respected and
you're right like the later we get in
the crown
he really does become this really smart
kind of level-headed
almost like cynical royal but he has
like a good head on
yeah like in the first few seasons yeah
things are dicey they're just like young
people
in love and like that comes with and he
wasn't born into this like he got thrown
into it and he definitely [ __ ] up with
the ballerina but
yes but as the seasons go on he's just a
mainstay in the family and i think
anytime someone goes to him for advice
or like
he's asked for advice he really has like
gave good advice and
i think as a smart man i think it will
will feel his loss
it's just like so crazy like he's so old
okay so it's 20 21 that means he was
born in 1921 like he was literally
born before the holocaust like that's
crazy
crazy that's what that would mean that's
what that would mean i like always
measure people's age and like how far
away they are from the holocaust
yeah not that far and he had some like
weird holocaust vibes with his family
like his family did but i don't i'm just
saying like
let me not forget like holocaust vibes
right the family his family was nazis
yeah like nazi sympathizers but not him
did i say him i just said he said he had
some i said he had nazi
vibes okay but like he didn't why if
you're surrounded by nazis that could
emulate nazi lives
he was at school
oh yeah yeah no i'm not saying in any
way that he's a nazi but like it's just
crazy that like there's literally
someone alive
who like knew nazis there's plenty of
people not there every day there's less
and less
there's plenty of people yeah crazy
crazy very sad we're thinking of the
queen and her queenie vibes
and may those queenie vi's carry her
through the difficult times ahead yeah
are you ready for our next story i
wonder if harry and megan will attend
the funeral i mean it's like
covid but funerals for royals are like
public right
oh i don't know what they're gonna do i
feel like they don't they like leave the
casket like for like
like a week i don't know i don't know i
don't know what they'll do either but
but yeah because like remember princess
diana's uh funeral like
harry and william like walked behind
there was a procession in the street
i don't know if they'll be that because
of covid but i'm just curious if harry
and megan will
fly to london to pay their respects
we'll see we shall see
time will tell you next up the other big
news of the day taylor swift has
released fearless taylor's version
six new songs from the vault re-recorded
all the other songs on the album
including like the deluxe platinum
version piano version of fearless like
and
she cop like did them to a t there is no
creative liberties being taken
she did not take my advice despite the
fact that there were some moments where
i was craving it well so
i was like feeling torn between really
wanting like a new album like i just
want new music from taylor so like take
your old stuff and change it and like
give us new music
and at the end of the day when i listen
to the album like it's pretty much a
replica uh with the new sub with the new
vault songs but all the old songs are
pretty much
exactly the same and as much as i was
like craving like yeah change lyrics
change tempos
i'm so glad that like the music that i
grew up loving i now can like listen to
and like feel good about it because like
taylor owns it and it really is exactly
the same and i feel like
for her records like they're pretty much
all going to be all the same because
like
this is music at least for like for the
swifty fandom like for me like
it's music that's important to me like i
want to go back and reference it and to
have like two different versions i'm
always going to want to listen to the
original but now the
the re-records are literally like the
originals so i think it was the smart
move
yeah she now owns like four out of nine
of her albums and of course she released
the recording on four nine so now i'm
thinking maybe like five nine six nine
seven nine eight nine nine nine is like
when we're gonna get
the record yeah i mean it's once a month
be like this big production and roll out
if it's just gonna be the exact same you
know it's nice she would also drop it
all like just at once yeah she could
that might be like overwhelming i like
the idea five nine six nine whatever you
get a month of like you know
the novelty of this but we don't need
like so much distance because it's not
really new
it's not music that we have to learn but
i do think that
every one of the re-records will have
new songs on it i think in order to be
able
like to be eligible to like release an
album twice
they have to have different songs on it
so i think that like
we'll get vault songs from red from 1989
i think eligible in what sense like i
don't think you can release the same
album twice if it's the exact same thing
like
without paying money to big machine okay
he still owns like the
licensing or whatever yeah i just think
it has to be different
okay i think i don't know i just feel
like she might as well put as many songs
every version if you're ever itching for
this one that one here it is for you you
don't need to wander over there a grade
a grade 100
100 so i haven't finished listening to
it yet i got up to forever and always
and then i had to
leave i got up to um
untouchable but i haven't listened to
the keith urban one yet but i'm so
excited i haven't listened to the vault
ones that we didn't already get
i'm really here for the oldies though
but these are oldies but the ones that
like i have memories with
yeah you know of course but i'm like
living for mr perfectly fine it's
so good so i'm hoping that there's going
to be some other vault songs that will
change my life you all over me is good
but it's not one that like i need to
like you know bury myself in the ground
for
i think i right now like you all over me
better than
mr perfectly fine but
to each your own yeah anything anything
can happen
i just like i feel like it has a more
contemporary sound whereas mr perfectly
fine is like
fearless 2008 right that's probably why
i like it like yeah
yeah are you ready for our next story
yeah i don't know you don't look ready
oh i don't okay hold on um travis barker
has a new tattoo oh my
might be attributed to kourtney
kardashian what do you mean might it
says
nipples that's the dumbest thing like
that would be like if i got a jewish
star on my back and they were like
claudia oscar has a new tattoo
might be attributed to her religion okay
sorry
i accidentally clicked like a a sidebar
article that was about like the other
tattoo that he got recently that's like
her
handwriting okay and she wrote like
you're so cute or something like that
this one travis barker debuts new tattoo
of kourtney kardashian okay okay a
little
more that's like the dumbest thing yeah
no they didn't say it like that though
travis is keeping girlfriend courtney
kardashian close to his heart
heart the rocker debuted a new tattoo on
thursday
courtney's first name is in script
inked above his left nipple yeah i think
it's more like
above his heart but but it's also about
his nipple it's really close
both you know i'm obsessed with kravis
like i think that they are such a great
couple
and i'm loving that their kids are
getting along and all that stuff
i'm a little nervous though it's very
hot and heavy
it's very like almost pete and ariana
you know
paparazzi everywhere a tattoo on her
foot like i'm just nervous let me tell
you
let me tell you how it's different okay
shall i count the ways first of all
travis barker is covered in tattoos for
him to get a tattoo if someone's not a
big deal
not a big deal it covered up something
else if they ever were to break like
he's not
they're not as like big of a deal for
him he gets them in his sleep and he
covers them up
when need be he also has his ex's name
tattooed i don't think
it says who's that shannon moekler oh
yeah right right right and she's also
the
mom of the kids right right so in the
tattoo realm
i don't think it's like pete and ariana
in the hot and heavy realm
these two have been friends for years
like they know each other there's a
foundation
if no i'm better you can explain your
way around it all but like it is
just a lot and i'm loving it but i'm
nervous because those things fizzle out
here's the thing
if the bones are good the rest don't
matter and first you have the bones
true and they're older than people and
ariana
kids they know who they are they know
what they want they know what they're
looking for they have a lot of
relationships in their past like
they have the makings of a good strong
foundation
therefore though on the surface it might
appear fast and quick and hot and heavy
i do not think it is i hope not i'm just
like nervous because i'm really invested
and like i really like them as a couple
and i would love this to be like you
know
otp for her but it's just a lot so i'm
it's like every day there's like new
photos new images new instagram new
photos new caption new comments by
celebs like
please like i'm just nervous also well
you can't blame them for like what other
people truly fanfare of other people
true also courtney doesn't act like this
like
it's not like she is always jumping
headfirst and like being so public with
her relationships if anything like this
is
new behavior from her which makes me
think
even more highly of it because she's
usually one who plays it
pretty close to the best yes i'm very
happy for her
i just really wanted to work out so i'm
just being you know cautious
cautiously optimistic for sure but you
should also enjoy this time
because if it's like you said it and
it's going to go away soon enjoy it
while you have it
i know you can't take it with you you
can't take credit just like that nobody
can take travis with you you can try but
you can't
um i'm happy for them and it's cute that
he got a tattoo it's obviously like not
a big deal for someone who's literally
head to toe covered in tattoos yes
that's all i'm saying yeah
our next story is some um pageant drama
sri lanka yeah i'm all
invested mrs world has been arrested
after grabbing newly crowned mrs
srilanka's tiara
off her head allegedly injuring her okay
like
did you see the video it's a little
dramatic but like arrested no i know
that's what i'm saying
it's wild miss so basically
the woman who won miss sri lanka it's a
pageant where you have to be married
and so when she won then the former
winner miss
from the previous year who had crowned
her said this is a pageant for married
women
we just found out you're divorced
grabbed the
crown off her head now the
alleged winner said she's not divorced
she is separated
and that she was assaulted when she got
the crown ripped off of her head
she was definitely embarrassed i don't
know if she was assaulted like i saw the
video
she just like took the crown off her
head i can't believe they actually
arrested that woman
i mean that's a crazy
series of events but like if she's
separated and she's in this competition
and someone took something off of her
person
you can press charges for that no you
can and honestly i would be pressing
charges too like just for the sheer
embarrassment of getting that crown
given to me and then taking off 100 like
i'm turning the tides because now mrs
world is arrested and
right she's the snatcher literally this
whole article is calling her this
crown snatcher and i'm just like she's a
crown she's a [ __ ] snatcher
no literally it's such a bizarre story
and is this the same pageant like would
this mystery lanka enter miss universe
no this is mrs world is that a different
yeah i think it's like now i'm realizing
we obviously we have miss usa in miss
america now it's like miss world and
miss universe
but there's also mrs america because
there's miss america
what for married women we have mrs
america
yeah but you can't win miss america if
you're married
that is so antiquated wait there's no
way you're that's true
there's not two competitions for
marriage about it like there's miss
and there's mrs america i believe that
they're i'm telling you there's not
like i don't think it gets as much you
know hype
and which one was kenya moore miss usa
miss america pageant oh my god
mrs america the mrs america pageant is a
beauty competition that was established
to honor
married women throughout the united
states of america
okay but i don't think it exists anymore
hold on 2005
no they had 20 20 and camille schreier
won oh my god an alan thicke hosted
wait i'm literally shook right so then
this is
like there's miss world and clearly
there's mrs world and she's a crown
snatcher
and is there miss universe and mrs
universe
and there's no i don't think so and
there's miss teen usa is there mrs teen
usa
what about the married teens what about
what about the married teens
this is when we separate we just need
one this is so stupid oh my god i cannot
believe this is mrs america pageant
so is there also a mrs united states
no i don't think so i get so confused by
pageants like
i know it's really confusing and miss
congeniality was mrs
miss united states she's beauty and
she's grace she's missed the united
states
usa miss united states yes yes but we
don't you don't call it miss united
states
you say miss usa right yeah i think
you're right like
i'm always trying to think when kenya
morrison's miss america no no that's a
separate pageant
kenny moore always says like you might
know me for being miss usa yeah
everywhere usa she's beauty
and she's grace she's miss united states
so so jess is for sri lanka yeah
but she's getting her justice yeah it's
crazy
crazy such a bizarre turn of events are
you ready for our fifth and final story
fifth and final story it's a final
story it's actually like not your usual
final story because it's just it never
is
no usually it's unusual but this is the
usual oh
andy cohen says two housewives are upset
over watch what happens live kids
special
andy cohen revealed on his radio show
first of all i will say i heard from two
moms yesterday
why wasn't my daughter included in the
watch what happens live special
he said it was just a lot to have 13
people he does not say
who the two real housewives are but that
is for us to speculate
he did confirm it was not sonya morgan
asking about quincy of course it would
not be sonia morgan
first of all lisa reyna also confirmed
that it wasn't her because a lot of
people were speculating that she would
be upset about delilah and amelia
and she like went on her instagram story
she's like i wanna know who the two moms
were who complained thus taking herself
out of the race
i have it on very good authority um even
though a lot of people speculated that
it was kyle richards it is 100 not kyle
richards
i found out for sure like it's not okay
so where does that leave us and it's
daughter like was lisa vanderpump mad
that it's not pandora no
pandora's like a little too old for like
it's not lisa vanderpump
let's go city by city okay i mean it's
not bryn
i got to go to new york it's not britain
it's not sonia morgan avery's on it
victoria dallas is on it liam mcsweeney
ally shapiro yeah someone said someone
messaged like ali shapiro should be on
it i totally agree
so i wonder if that was one of them
definitely
but i don't know but jill like i don't
know
i do think ali should be on it me too
and i do think joe might have been one
to complain okay okay i think we found
one okay
jersey oh also there's not a potomac
kid kid here who has a daughter like
karen
giselle i know but they're like not on
the show
that much yeah and they didn't grow up
on the show the show was still like kind
of early
is anyone from dallas no dallas and
potomac are like the same age
oh yeah but like he he made such a
splash like
dallas we have carrie's kids yeah but
they also are not on that much i
don't know anything about them we know
the one better than the others but then
i saw the others and they all look the
same and they're all the same age and
honestly with dallas a lot
because they're in the olivia jade yes
they're all younger
that i feel like honestly the kids are
still like
like hilton is what like seven like
we're not gonna have a seven-year-old no
i think it was hilton complaining me too
um okay but so let's go to like the og
franchises because i think okay atlanta
we have
brielle um riley riley
and and i think we're fun oh and cairo
and and
uh noel cynthia yeah so
atlanta i don't think i think it's
probably someone from beverly hills in
new jersey oh see
but there's so many rand oh shannon
tamara
no tamara's kids no shannon shannon
yeah i mean dream catcher
what was that song they wrote i don't
know but it was dreamcatcher
he was so good she has a number of kids
who could have participated
shannon is interesting
bronwyn i mean
yeah but like she puts her kids on the
show a lot i feel like maybe it could
have been her like doesn't mean she has
ground to stand on to complain
yeah but she might have complained i
don't know though that would take balls
we think about jersey you think it was
like melissa gorga like antonia but she
also was like not even on the show like
yeah star
yeah anyone else daughters from jer oh
danielle stabbed
you think danielle stabbed
yeah because her kids were like a
fixture on that and like i would love to
hear from them like
when theresa flipped that table on your
mom and then like the gear after that
like
what was it like i did hear from them
when theresa had to go apologize
oh i guess yeah like i'm good on that
storyline but i could see danielle's
child
complaining yeah do all the housewives
like have andy's phone number like how
do they that's what i was going to say
like
at what point did they get cut off like
you're no longer a part of this like
business you can't call andy and i think
that even like
when you are a part of the business not
all of them have relationships with andy
like not all of them have andy's phone
number they probably know him on watch
robin's live like
but not in a personal way i think a lot
of the new york housewives know him
personally just because
he lives in new york and the beverly
hills ones because they're like
celebrities and andy's a celebrity
and the ogs like i think the atlanta
women have a good relationship with him
i'm sure they all have his phone number
not the new ones but
same with jersey yeah but like does
carrie brittingham have no number i
actually don't think any of the dallas
housewives have his number
yeah no it's interesting and like some
of them are like
like bethany and him are like best
friends like they like hang out in the
hamptons all together
so that's like unfair you know yeah but
she's not a housewife anymore so
so it works yeah so those were the five
past five stories so i think we landed
on possibly danielle staub
jill zarin and shanna bador yeah i'm
going
jill's bronwyn i'm voting jill
and shannon i think i am too or jill and
stabb um well those are the fast five
stories yes as you said
and i feel as though you needed to know
them i i would agree yeah
um let's dive into our tv recap which is
uh keeping up with the kardashians on e
last night
it was an episode that was highly
anticipated that addison ray of it all
making her appearance first cameo on
keeping up with the kardashians she is
just such a star like she's so smiley
she's so cute she's like so
i actually i actually understand why
courtney like a 40 year old woman wants
to hang out with like
magnetic she has that energy and you
know i definitely when i first saw
started seeing them hanging out like i
definitely thought it was weird um but
the way they kind of described like how
they met
and then just like how they stayed
friends
i totally understood and honestly the
more i thought about like most of the
people in my life who are like my best
friends are like literally 15 years
older than me like it's not weird
no it's it's not super weird
and you just have to see her like to
understand yeah
she just she has that energy first of
all she's a star like
she just sitting at dinner or lunch with
all of them like
interrogating her she can handle it she
is a star like she's gonna be huge i've
always felt that way last night's
episode cemented it
but then also like they all ended up
really liking her because she's just
like a fun
even beyond like being a star she just
seems like a fun nice cool girl who like
gets along well with others
yes yes what's not to like no there's
nothing not to like
she's like so nice with the kids and
they have like grown-up fun like that
party looked turned
yeah um when they were like we're going
in the ocean it's like crazy
no like it's crazy yeah but like um them
showing up in matching outfits like that
was a little extreme for me
oh no i liked it extreme i liked it i
she was a breath of fresh air i hope
she's on more episodes
that you know have other good story
lines that didn't take me two hours to
watch because it was so goddamn boring
it was literally one of the worst
episodes i've ever seen yeah so then
like the other random story lines
honestly we didn't get enough chris
jenner in this episode and that's
why i feel like it was a flop of an
episode yeah but like also corey
is so funny to me because like hanging
out with adam's party with courtney
addison sarah howard and corey sarah
howard fitness and health guru smoking a
jewel
and uh harry yeah yeah like what a rant
of course and then i'm like why is queer
and then when they all ran in the ocean
sarah addison courtney and
corey i was like corey go home to your
wife
like it was so random i was dying no but
like
what a good time yeah cory is the good
time guy i think that's why like they
really like having him around like he
chaperones all the parties like he takes
kylie to clubs like yeah he's
he's like a protector of sorts and he's
also a good time guy he's like a man
about town
knows the best spots no i love him so
much
life goal like get to a party and like
be one of corey gamble's like hanger
honors
yeah true realistic i think so
i hope we see more addison it looks like
she's at the house all the time so if
if going forward she's not like in more
scenes i'm gonna be like oh then
everything about that last episode was
just like planned like her playing
cornhole with the kids like you don't
just go over here and play cornhole
right
um second subplot was mj's birthday like
what should we do should we go to the
hotel
chris was right obviously mj who's older
should not be going to like a public
hotel for her birthday
because this was what like six months
ago in l.a when things were really bad
but of course like the kardashians being
like
what do we do like of course you know
what you're gonna do like you threw in
you flew in a uh clinic you got everyone
tested
her friends quarantined and of course
like it was fine we were outside we were
wearing masks
like the whole conundrum of like what do
we do like as if you don't have
unlimited resources was just a little
stupid right you could have shut down
the hotel for the day
flew the clinic in right you didn't have
to bring rick ross the rapper slash
um like you could have just went to him
like it was so stupid but
at the end it was actually a really nice
party i agree and i really like the
message of it of just like living life
to the fullest yeah i'm just like
enjoying your time here
on earth and so by then i was cool with
it but like in the middle of the episode
i was just like i have
literally no time for this i have a book
i want to get back to yeah but at the
actual party like i did get like choked
up and it was like every time
like i think they just like know that
their time with
mj is limited it's limited and they have
so much respect for her and they all
showed up even though like they're no
one goes to everyone's
like at someone's birthday dinner no
one's ever there kim everyone was there
except for kylie
um and i just i loved that and that's
like that's like why i love them like
they're fan like their respect for
family they're
like they just love each other so much
and actually thought that storyline
ended nicely but it was a journey thank
you it ended beautifully
and it was a stunning party like looked
so much fun mj had her sensei
like it was lovely but then the sub sub
sub oh actually before the sub sub
subplot jonathan's robbery yeah
that was actually crazy i can't believe
they caught that on camera of him
calling kim
before the police even arrived and kim
is such a good friend like just come
here come here like we'll take care of
you
but that was actually really scary i
remember when we reported on it and i
remember when it happened and i texted
him and i was like oh man are you
[ __ ] okay
he said like literally was the scariest
moment of his life like they literally
held up a gun to his mom's head like
that's so [ __ ] scary so [ __ ] scary
so even though everyone always jokes
about
food god like really scary yeah and i'm
glad he's okay and of course
that triggered something in kim but the
storyline that proceeded after that was
so silly like i
couldn't except i kind of loved the uh
bunker builder wearing the obama shirt
flushing his nipples to chloe on zoom oh
yeah like
a ship loved him also when chloe was on
zoom with him being like yeah take it
off sexy it was like kind of like old
chloe vibes and i was like
wow she really has changed and it made
me sad because i feel like she's so much
more
protective of herself now and she used
to be like so open and
fun not that she's not those things but
like it was just
showed me how much like things had
changed for her i agree completely i
like i was smiling at that zoom scene
when it was like like a nothing burger
yeah it just felt like very old chloe in
a good way
then they went to the bunker uh kimmy
schmidt and the mole women
and they just laid there for three hours
played cards and studied
i'm sure they didn't actually stay there
for five hours i'm sure like editing
made it seem longer they're probably
there for like 30 minutes just like
pretending to be there for five hours oh
um because like kim was like it's so hot
in here they were like making the
degrees 100 for it like neither one of
them were sweating
they weren't even shiny that's true they
weren't even shiny i feel like kim
goes out of her way to not sweat you
know like i don't think she's a big
sweater no i know but like okay in a
bunker and 104 degrees like
some it's not up to you i don't know it
was just so bad
it was so stupid i think maybe i won't
get a bunker
oh truckers for bunkers truckers against
bunkers that's us
that's them yeah no it was beyond stupid
i would have thought i could watch like
them do anything
i guess i have my limits yeah it was
really stupid like i was really getting
bored and i was like getting like
um like claustrophobic for them
yeah with because also it was like two
of them in there and then also what like
four cameras no it was
horrible it was horrible so it was like
a subpar episode but again it's the
final season so we just have to enjoy
each moment i just like because it was
the final season i just assumed i was
gonna enjoy every minute and like i
really did not enjoy it i know
but that happens things happen things do
happen
that is our tv recap and that is our
show
yes it is and that is our week like i'm
so [ __ ] excited to just
roll out the weekend in front of me take
it in
soak it up soak up each other's
weekendness yeah we've got a big weekend
ahead of us yeah we do i'm hosting
shabbat at my home this evening it's
gonna be lovely
um i would come full and
that's my advice to you guys i hope
everyone has a shabbat shalom
a happy and healthy weekend stay safe
don't drink and drive take care of
yourselves
listen to your body and be kind to one
another thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast the millennial
morning show where we deliver the fast
effect stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so it's a spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i hate ready to cast box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find out more until sleep pops
are you better beautiful signing and
smart we are
hoping an amazing day see you on monday
goodbye